La is just different now what does that
mean it doesn't mean everything you're
the king bro everything is [ __ ] it's
your fault it's just yeah yeah it's not
my fault dude I just left the castle
burned down though that was the last cat
like what happened you gotta build it
back up the opportunity we're trying but
it doesn't feel like you're trying
Bobby's in Hawaii every other week
you're never nowhere I'm never there
because because you don't want it it's
segmented you don't want it nah dude I
you don't want that I don't want it the
problem is
there's a lot of stolen tools on the
ground you know what I mean like you
take it you're like talk to me like I
don't know who who are this before man
Sally wash their hair if
yeah you remember La feels dirty it just
feels like everyone's got a gun out
there is no sense of community we talked
about this before the show and it
doesn't feel like doesn't come up down
though bro yeah but but the problem
but because they left now everyone kind
of feels like they're in their own
little competitive Circle because
they're waiting for somebody to extend
the Olive Branch man that's the Netflix
special and maybe a couple movies with
Kevin Hart yeah I need another one Kev I
don't know what Kevin you know we should
call we can call him that is the thing
I've noticed especially in like this in
this career it's like everybody is
naturally kind of out for themselves
right because they have to work their
entire life to get to this point right
and they think that I'm not saying
everybody thinks a lot of people think
like oh if I'm helping this person if
I'm using resources to help that person
maybe I won't get the thing I want right
and the way Joe flipped it on his head
is he's like I'm just gonna help
everybody and then it just made him
so much bigger because it was almost
like the Drake formula where it's like
Drake puts on everybody and then
everybody is Drake Drake is everybody's
biggest The Tide Rises All Ships you
know whatever yeah yeah
it truly is now everybody but he was at
a high level when he did that the
problem is like you need to reach a
level where you're kind of one of the
only ones on there and then go all right
let's go I'm gonna pull everything the
level where you like sell out four shows
at the Wilbur no no no no the level is
the level is where you are you have so
much of a history in comedy that's built
in that you've built up where everybody
kind of looks to you a little bit
already like everyone kind of looked to
Joe already to be like what is he doing
on the next thing people have to think
there's anybody that could do it like I
know I know loves helping people that
sounds like yeah that sounds like an
excuse coming from uh Andrew
I think that sounds like an excuse me
I'm not big enough you got to be a big
enough because there's a lot of guys
that are bigger than me in LA but
they're not taking it like Jeselnik is
is bigger than me and he's an LA guy and
he's not that's not his thing you know
shots fired is there anybody stealing
jokes you got to call him out on stage
imagine imagine they let men see you
back into the store I clip him again
create the video
bring Arya on stage again the whole deal
yeah
but also it's like there is something
about the time in L.A that's so
fragmented now like everyone is kind of
going their own way it is now there's
not okay like when there is a benevolent
King everybody knows who is potentially
their savior yeah right so everybody
knows how to you know fall in line fall
in line is kind of what it's like we
were talking about this the other day
about like stories but like essentially
all like the stories in the Bible or
something like that just reinforce the
behavior of the tribe right it's like
every story is like hey this is how you
should act right this is how you should
treat people and my privilege by the way
that's what that was that was white
privilege Browns then Browns wrote that
yeah
we were up north mind our own [ __ ]
business until you brought your goddamn
Christianity
multiple gods yeah yeah
you were where are we Norseman Brothers
yeah and then Black Jesus came through
and these [ __ ] blacks in there Jesus
Son you're welcome
yeah the first time that they the first
time I decided
he's really invent Heaven because even
like your white parties are just like
heaven like it's the same idea
uh that's a good point heaven on Earth
baby
you don't think he was tan
he was dark
but maybe he was black he was like Jeter
cheetah you know
you think he's kind of like him what
about Al you think I Think Jesus could
be like oh no me yeah with the shape up
a little too much in the sun he might do
it because it had to be somewhere in the
middle it had to be like just tan I like
how white people are willing to give
Middle Eastern but they're like yeah
for years it was like blonde hair blue
eyes and I was like all righty Thomas
because he pressed to me he could have
been all of us he's not brown uh bronze
skin and curly hair I don't see it I
mean he literally is that yeah yeah look
at that bronze I think he's dead look
take off your glasses
you're really splitting hairs here
you're splitting curly hair bronze
you're pretty close you should probably
as close to bronze as you can get yeah
all right [ __ ] he will be anyways
yeah no it is I think you look more like
that point I'm saying is is the guy that
everybody was looking to right was the
guy who was the most generous and and so
everybody was like all right well I
better act accordingly like you know if
I wanted not generous I'm not gonna get
on Rogan ever see me being shitty you
know so he's still doing it
self-servingly but the king is setting a
precedent where you're where everybody
needs to be benevolent
[ __ ] tone bro you're not moving to
New York then I switched it up I'm
staying because
[Music]
I love this for you the king is bad
no it no it's something things need to
change out there but I think it's just a
time and comedy needs to shift again too
we've talked what I've talked about this
everyone talks about like what club is
doing better or what club is doing the
best well the store is always kind of a
standby you know what I mean but like
The Improv took a big dip and now the
Improv is back a little bit but they all
kind of go through these waves so does
the city of Comedy it's just that's the
way La has always operated because
comedy in New York is uh and we don't
have to [ __ ] go inside baseball
enough some of these fans are like
[ __ ] checking out but comedy in New
York is Ever Changing with the this the
city itself you're not attached to the
business we still have a piece of us
that are attached to the business so
it's either because he means like
Hollywood it's part of our culture so
like it's inherently going to affect
who's doing stand up and who's staying
in La for a while and it changes the
scene that doesn't happen here I mean it
just is not a part of the culture yeah
yeah yeah and whether or not it's like
super deliberate it it just happens it
ends up being a part of it 100 so I
think that's kind of part of LA's growth
Cycles are when it's humming and things
are working and young people are getting
up and getting more in Hollywood and
their names become bigger and it helps
the scene in La kind of grow and Thrive
I also think part of the Rogan thing was
because people who moved to LA you're
like you said you're drawn to even if
you're a comic you're drawn to show
business in Hollywood yeah once Rogan
popped up it's like oh maybe I can make
money without that I don't need to cater
to that yeah that was a that's a healthy
way to think because he made it possible
for people to even feel that way even if
it wasn't going to be true maybe you
need to remind them you know what I mean
yeah I don't want to maybe you need to
get some more bad friends
is it also possible that uh people are
more reluctant to get as close to one
another because we don't know what their
other people are doing in their projects
I think it's less I think that I think
it's document I think people think that
yeah
I think I know what you mean but I think
truly it's more about we're so
self-serving as Comics everyone is
selfish every comic you know is a
selfish person oh yeah your degrees of
selfishness are very but because we're
self-serving that City makes you even
more self-serving because I don't have
to see you dude I can get in my car go
to a spot and I can go home to my family
and people can do that every night of
the week see Schultz is sick oh sorry
slick I can't even talk yeah yeah I do
what I do yeah there's always room for
one New York Andrew that's why you're
trying to keep him alive
but now I need to do reverse psychology
now I need to get you to New York oh
yeah you know they made documentaries
illegal here yeah
they literally they need documentaries
all right everybody in L.A
hey I'm coming I'm moving I wanted to
change though I do want to come here for
a while because I want to feel something
different for a while what do you want
to feel
I just want a new scene man I want a new
I want to I want to do I want to work
the clubs here and I also want a just a
little bit different trying to find
yourself you know yeah but this is this
is your India you know what
this is this is you know what I've said
before I'm 40 this year yeah oh [ __ ] I
don't like midlife crisis I like midlife
assessment you're reassessing where
you're going and what you want I hate
the term I think it is
it's a midlife it smells so [ __ ] old
dogs
it tasted life though this idea that
like a guy reaches midlife and then
starts buying like nice [ __ ] he's having
a crisis it's it takes your whole life
to have the money to buy it that's what
it really is it's not a crisis no we
have to buy things for ourselves you
finally got it yeah I worked hard yeah
yeah for [ __ ] 20 straight years it
came to me so you can move to a real
City
I would have earned it I want it because
I want it because uh you're sick of them
[ __ ] Jews running home that's what
you said
you can't say these things that's
anti-semitic when you say that dude I
I think that's doing a good job
I like all the movies
I want to cut to like a commercial of
you reading like a noping like I am not
anti-semitic I pronounce anti-Semitism
to all of my friends and brothers in the
yeah please if I was leaving Hollywood
because of Jews you think I'd move to
New York it's like the worst move I've
ever made a Williamsburg baby yeah and
walking into it nice I I but I do think
uh I just want to feel something
different and also are you bringing the
wife out are you going to keep her out
there no no no she stays in L.A you're a
real man bro no she's excited she's a
real man dude yeah that's real man [ __ ]
yeah you stay here
wait for me baby how did you even break
it to her like uh she's chained up
whoa no I do you know what I said you
know what I said both cue the
documentaries
[Laughter]
I actually asked her I said I said uh
because we had some stuff in our family
lives that affected us deeply that was
real that personal stuff in our family
lives both of our families some [ __ ] you
know uh Bobby make fun of you about it
because I saw a clip of that that was
very insensitive yeah he's an
insensitive piece of [ __ ] about I talk
about it in my special that my like my
dad you know got diagnosed with cancer
and it's going to be okay but like it
affected us in a way where we started to
like type one time and I get into it
okay but it was all like it affected us
in a way where I was like oh [ __ ] I
really wanted are we gonna see are we
gonna see my um how many more times am I
going to see my dad you want to be you
want to be that's what I thought like
maybe we want to let's change our lives
to go in well you know I got skin cancer
that's coming no matter what you can't
escape skin I was like how many more
years do I have left yeah with family
with family as a whole just an idea so I
was like do we want to be stuck out here
or can we have more freedoms to go where
we want to go and pull my family to
different places Maybe I'm not going to
tell you man
but is it something he can find out no
he's fine he's good so he's survived it
he's going to be okay it's it
but it's called the colon is it you
cannot just keep a lot of questions
he's going to be fine but it just like
it got me yeah you can't keep asking me
doesn't want to touch this girl don't
don't know
[Laughter]
did you feel
you feel he felt it on his chin
you do mouth tests I don't do mouth
tests with your boys mouth test and you
just that's how we tested
when you got a sore throat we dip you
can always feel which weight of the
tongue is heavier